bonsoir bonsoir
change certaines
que je me retrouvais de ce soir face à
vous pour cette 47e cérémonie des césar
nous allons accueillir cette sublime
que me suis plaint chet
bon gibert bibiche
tu sais regard des quartiers nord ça
s'arrête là bas
concentrez vous sur ce qu'on entend
adroits aux yeux et dit moi que je
[Musique]
que tu sois passé
e
je n'espère plus rien je commençais les
nommés aux césar pour le meilleur soumis
[Musique]
excusez moi c'est pas les césar ce soit
non c'est le 25 février monsieur joe
cole
bon
47e cérémonie des césar en clair et en
direct seulement sur canal+
le casting et leur cousine
je trouvais vrai